girls breakfast because we're leaving
let's go
leaving i wanna i don't have time to
work out
bam eleven o'clock we need to be out i
know that's why i'm trying to rush
everybody along it's already what time
is it ten
if anyone finds a sock down there it's
mine
hi guys hi
how are you morning how are you i'm
sorry i wouldn't get pictures of your
boyfriend you posted i i missed him
no kidding that
taking a picture of a hammock last night
with this big smile
louie loves him
and i'm like
no
i um i had a conversation with my guy in
tulum this morning now how were you guys
talking about he's coming uh in may to
the hamptons oh i've always wanted to
have a latin lover and now i have one
and we see each other when we see each
other there's no strings attached and
it's easy breezy i think it's important
that people enjoy their sexuality and
have sex because i think it's very good
for the soul so i'd love to take him to
like some sort of exotic something like
really swanky sexy senior show
he hasn't seen my show because of cover
same with erica did you guys get to see
her in chicago she looked like she did
like she just
that's a lot nene did it on our show
yeah and candy did it and we got some
talent from atlanta i know on broadway
yeah
they asked me to play mom remorse i mean
and that you brought up nene do you guys
still talk
not really um
i just don't enjoy talking about it and
i get asked about it all the time i will
always have love for her but i'm fine
with not being friends with her
what i've learned with my relationship
with nene is that communication is key
last night for my bailey queue
yes
two and what are you doing i just went
to my feet off with kenya you know the
energy seems weird like i don't really
know what's going on that's tough i you
know i survived needy i don't know if i
can survive nene king you know that's a
lot i think it reminds me of you and
nina with me and jacqueline and me and
jaclyn were really close like we were
friends before the show i mean i'm the
most loving person there is you know i
mean quit when you're ahead
jaclyn tell her this i've won her nine
years i would have never crossed her and
she crossed me
somebody could have been putting that
story out and they did about the jail
thing
can you understand how is identified
better i can't you put it in a tablet
you were going through legal issues i
never asked you a question
mine wasn't a criminal case
you wouldn't file fraudulent bankruptcy
like you did see that that's a low blow
that was it and and i was so heartbroken
it was like really hard for me to
deal with that because it was like no it
was so devastating yeah i really was
like i was really like i literally
talked to nene probably 30 times a day
every day yeah being her too we
just
had that we just had something yeah we
used to talk about hours yeah in special
chemistry and i'm like well i don't
understand why
the biggest problem
in these friendships
in reality television is some of these
women care more about what the audience
think
than what their friends think the show
does put pressure on you but if you
allow it to put pressure on you so if a
relationship goes sour it's not the
show's fault it ends up
exposing people that are really not
there for you she brought up like
my legal stuff a true fan would have
never brought that up on actual tv right
it's not your real friend she's my best
friend right you're close to erica right
and like if she tells you like don't
bring up my legal stuff
you're not gonna bring up her legal
stuff on tv
no but the thing is they know that she's
going through that that's coming up
right you know what so then i i ask
questions that can give her you know
like then i know we'll give her a chance
to explain
her cider you know i mean just like this
is a great topic i love this topic
because we know it's out there and the
paper is right so how much can we guard
our friend oh i know it sounds so bad
you know i know the red dots on my head
and it's a terrible thing
at least you know it's coming instead of
just getting your head blown off well
like i did with bethany she showed me a
picture on camera that i was not
expecting then my husband was kissing
somebody else i remember that that was
it was terrible
i think i'm gonna throw up
and then it's wednesday night so that's
at the well whatever you ask whatever
you want to know so you're saying that
bethany should have told you first like
hey i have this obviously
well she claims to be my friend that's
not fair
bethany's agenda's always been to have
the spotlight on her it was really more
about her than it was about me i'm glad
that bethany showed me the picture but
i'm not happy that she showed me on
camera because it was a very tough thing
to go through for the whole world to sit
you would have never done that to me
i'm not doing this phrase never this is
your husband i was like your wedding i
don't know i know cause you're a good
human good humans don't do that stuff i
don't care if it's for the sake of
television good humans don't do that
[Music]
are you ready